votre point mais qui est le principal
utilisateur du dégroupage dans ce pays
orange
donc quand on monte les prix du
dégroupage quel est le seul qui est
jamais touché c'est lui je vous le redis
ça je.fr ADSL 19,99 fibre optique 29,99
et ouais et quand on monte les prix du
découpage Sosh 1999 fibre optique 29,99
et donc on va pas monter nos prix et
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire et bien on va
faire du transfert financier vers Orange
et qu'est-ce qu'on va faire et bien on
va pousser orange de se dépêcher de
surtout pas éteindre le cuivre parce que
à partir de ce moment là ils vont perdre
ses abonnés dans une concurrence réelle
parce que quand vous allez avoir le prix
du dégroupage à 20 euros hors taxes qui
vont vendre une offre à 19,99 TTC et que
nous on l'attendra aussi à 19,4 cet été
c'est quoi mais pourquoi ils ne pourront
pas mais pour quelle raison il le vende
à 19 mais il le vendent déjà à perdre
quand il le vendait 1999 aujourd'hui
vous faites quelque chose là-dessus rien
mais personne ne fait rien sur le sujet
on a fait 20 ans de procédure là-dessus
orange a été condamné quoi 15 fois en
procédure concurrentielle mais ça prend
10 ans ils seront condamnés dans 10 ans
mais ça sera trop tard et donc le sujet
quand on augmente le prix du dégroupage
aujourd'hui on vous donne une rampe de
situation orange et des parts de marché
orange et bah c'est pour ça qu'on est
contre parce qu'on pense que c'est une
erreur par contre si on dit on revient à
cette question nous augmenterons les
prix du dégroupage le jour où dans un an
jour pour jour vous allez fermer le
réseau alors là tout le monde va se
presser y compris orange tout le monde
va se presser et c'est une autre demande
ah non c'est pas ça l'idée aujourd'hui
c'est de dire
est disponible super et ben dans ce
cas-là éteignant de cuivre pourquoi on
éteint pas le cuve à cet endroit là
et ben on est d'accord on va on va
laisser monsieur
et donc pour nous nous sommes ok pour
une hausse du dégroupage un an avant la
fermeture pratique du réseau et même que
ça soit des réguliers c'est pas un sujet
on voit regarder les prix je vous
rappelle qu'il doit y être des
obligations d'orientation mais faut que
ça soit fait un an pas 5 ans avant et
aujourd'hui ce qu'on nous vend c'est 5
ans avec une Arcep complètement acquise
à Orange qui se couche devant orange et
c'est ça mon sujet et c'est ça notre
sujet aujourd'hui sur le New Deal le
[Musique]